I think mental content is the ultimate
privilege because you described yourself
as being as happy you've always had this
this drive this motivation is there a
risk in Us in trying to advise others
when they don't have the same privilege
I have no belief that I'm right I don't
think people should listen to me I think
people should listen to everything and
try to find positivity and usability out
of everything and they should dismiss
what is clearly negative and selfish and
they should triple down on everything
that is selfless and positive lean in
dramatically more to things that are
positive your grandfather podcasts
upworthy.com then they should be on the
awareness on is this delusional and
lacks practicality like you know if I
just dream it it will happen no and so
back to your point we're gonna put out
stuff forever because it's how we're
wired the people we're listening right
now they need to understand where they
match with us you and I match on a lot
of things there's a lot of things we
don't match on the person on the other
side needs to figure it out